all right so now we're going to compute
a square root but we're doing for an
actual number because it'd be much
easier and do with algebra okay so for
example he's my table yet okay
he's my example this theory is what I
needed to establish stuff up here I'm
gonna say now therefore the square root
of Zin is I just established
Zed's a complex number the square root Z
must also be a complex number
okay so I'm gonna write it like this X
plus I don't know what X is I don't know
what my is but it's gonna be a real part
and an imaginary part okay now just like
I did up here with my complex root that
I didn't know right I'm going to square
both sides because then I know what Z is
right so if I square both sides I get is
do you agree with that is that okay oh
sorry that's just zip right that's done
okay so I sprayed the left-hand side the
square root disappeared I squared the
right-hand side so I just have that okay
now I know what sin is in this
particular case I've got a value for it
so I'll just shoot that it now on the
right hand side I'm just multiplying
complex number by itself right this X
plus I Y times X plus iy that's fine
this is just like a normal binomial yeah
so when I expand this what do I get x
squared plus 2/5 X y plus I squared y
squared
now you might just go straight to that
minus sign if you like as I mentioned
before because we're still fairly early
I'm gonna write I squared and I don't
wanna confuse the side okay so I've got
this let's just rearrange just ever so
slightly to make it clear what the real
part is I want the imaginary part so I
got x squared and
is real this I squared Y squared is real
right it's minus y squared do you bury
that that's the real components the real
part and then what I'm left with is I'll
stick that I out the front to it make
very obvious that this is imaginary and
left me two x one you care that now just
to make it clear all I'm gonna rewrite
it over here on the left hand side and
now you can see just like we've done so
many times in quadratic Theory intrigue
when we did auxiliary angle right can
you see on the left hand side there's a
real pot and on the right hand side
there's a real pot yes on the left hand
side there's an imaginary part and on
the right hand side there's an imaginary
part so by comparison of coefficients I
know that the root pot the good pot must
be the same because remember real and
imaginary cannot mix they're two
different things okay
question yes yes I should thank you for
catching that there is this color which
I'm graduation because it will become
crucial to us shortly okay
great pickup all right now therefore I
can say I can equate the real and
imaginary composing in fact I'm even
going to say that okay equating real
this is analogous to when I compared
coefficients like how many sine x is do
I have on this side of this side
how many cause X's do I have them
deciding this side I'm equating I'm
comparing those two out of this I'm just
going to go straight up to the um after
the sidewalks and then start working
with these I see that x squared minus y
squared equals negative 5
- XY equals 12 you comfortable that see
what I thought it's a simple comparison
of those coefficient laws now what I've
got here is two simultaneous equations
and I have two variables namely
x and y okay in some senses you can work
this out the blue yourself you don't
need my help down like this is just
gonna be it's gonna end up as a
quadratic okay I'll pay this out first
time let's walk through it together okay
simultaneous equations you've got two
broad strategies for solving
simultaneous equation one side to the
next one start to the need you mean what
they are substitution and elimination
okay which do you think will be more
helpful substitution is gonna be the
only option really because there's
nothing in common really that will
properly eliminate you see that it's not
like I have a wire to Y here there's
nothing I can multiply by in terms of
constant that won't get me out of here
so I need just substitute you can see
it's gonna be much easier to work with
this guy right so I'm gonna say Y who's
12 on 2x happy with that which is six on
X so now I have something I can
substitute out let's go straight back to
equation one and I'm gonna write it X
sway I take away what to it forget to
square six 36 over x squared
yeah cuz I know what Y is and so putting
in Y squared you might have put it 6
over X 4 squared that's also fun okay
that's equal to negative 5 is this a
quadratic now as you will see in a few
seconds this is not a quadratic it is
according but that doesn't mean I can't
still handle it as a quadratic watch
it's multiplied through I get this
I multiplied through by X right and by
the way the reason sine x squared and
the reason why I can do that is because
x squared is not 0 how do I know that
I'll let you ever think about it as to
why x squared is not 0 how do I know
that the real arts are the proper formal
answer for y will come a bit later okay
so there's this right but in a sense I
did that the question didn't do that I
did that right but you're pretty close
then anyone see look just look up here
just look up here if X were 0 there's no
solution to this right it kind of water
this there's no value can put in Y that
will make this satisfied ok so that's
how I know it's not an answer
okay now this is not a quadratic it's a
quartic but that doesn't matter if I
just put that x squared term over here
it's fine I can work with it just like I
would work with a quadratic because it's
an equation I can reduce to a quadratic
you don't even really know that if I
imagine this is U squared and this was u
u square plus v nu minus 36 this is even
easy to factorize what's the
factorization
yes exactly
well and you shouldn't be surprised at
that because if I swapped like what is
equal to six on X but X is equal to 6 or
Y yeah you sure you see this it's this
what we call symmetrical right so it's
you can end up in this empty
okay now as being so pointed out right x
and y are real x and y are real
so therefore this part here huh
like I'm like cool I'm in the complex
hope I can solve this but we don't want
to we only want to think about for X the
real numbers right so I would say no
real solution lots of that part all
right
4x squared plus 9 what real number can
you put in there to make it true because
x and y are the coefficients of here and
the coefficients are real the whole
number is complex but the coefficients
are real okay yeah okay now nervously
should man but I do get two solutions
out of this guy right one of my answers
for X also - to you care with that okay
now let's consider these one at a time
I'll go x equals plus 2 or x equals
minus 2 if X is positive 2 therefore Y
is equal to 3 if X is negative 2 then Y
is equal to negative 3
okay so now out of these two lines 1 & 2
I have two complex numbers right you see
that's each one is a is a complex number
so I've got here 2 plus 3i that's one
solution and then here I've got minus 2
minus 3i
voters are the square roots this number
here okay now you'll notice there are
two there are two square roots now B
usually uh but you gotta be careful
right widows say what's the square root
of twenty-five right
that's my thoughts I mean it's five and
I don't mean it's minus five okay now
hold on a second why when I'm over in
this land why saying is one solution but
here when I'm in this land I say you
know what there are two solutions why am
i okay with two solutions here but I
restrict it here I'll just tease an
answer for you by showing you a bit of
arithmetic okay I'm just gonna tease an
answer
the reason why I say this is because I
can say this yeah UK with that you agree
with that right spirit five certifier
script 45 yes but if I were to say if I
were to with you know allow within my
definition of the square root of 25 if I
were to permit this then I would be able
to say this
but the fact is I cannot I call it
do you see why what's going on here
I've got the square root of five using
our language now which is more powerful
that's the square root of 5i right times
the square root of five
hi do you agree with that but I know
what this is equal to is that I squared
there which is that's not very 25 X is
minus root 25 did you see that okay so
you see when I say this equals this the
reason why is because I can't play with
these guys
right I haven't developed the
mathematics to deal with the complex
numbers that arise from letting in this
time and saying this a can't but now
that I mean the complex world right
these are just fine like I can deal with
either of these you know and no rules we
break and unlike here right because I'm
safely in the complex well and you can
test it out you can go ahead you can do
2 plus 3i that's quickly square it shall
we help me out oh sorry 4 plus plus 12 5
plus 9i squared that's minus 9 minus 5
plus 2i you don't even really need to
compute the other one right it's kind of
obvious why this has to equal the same
just a second forget it why is it
obvious because I can take out a factor
of minus 1 here can I so this is B
bracket minus 2 plus 3i or squared but
that means there's a minus 1 times minus
1 which is just 2 plus 3i squared which
I just calculated right so you can see
in fact in some sense is once I get this
I don't really need to worry about this
guy it's just kind of implied right